November 15th 2018 I'm starting all over
again
with nothing to become financially free
from scratch as per the requests but
right now this week's video good morning
guys hope you good
Samuel leaves here and can you believe
it is already September today myself my
wife and my baby girl are gonna be going
to the seaside not to hang to the beach
we might hang to the beach a little bit
but we're going to be we've booked 10
viewing so we're going to be viewing 10
properties I think a couple of
counselled so let's see what we can get
into and let's see what happens things
do take twice as long with this leg but
because I'm prepared to work twice as
hard I'm more than twice as smaller than
most people I'm still going to get more
than double resorts Robeck have you got
your return on investment calculator so
why weston-super-mare well I think that
the Cubs depreciation is going to be
great
Chapas depreciation does not play the
bells but the return on investments
pretty decent turn so I mean this first
one that we're doing I think I think
it's gone 490 there's a tenant in there
a sitting tenant paying 600 that wants
to stay nice condition so the returns
probably I mean I don't know what that
would work out at and with apartments
you've got of course you've got ground
rent and service charges but it's
probably about 15% which isn't amazing
so what we're trying to do today we're
trying to find a property there's gonna
give us a 20% ROI but also with the
likelihood that we're going to get a
nice capital appreciation if we could
also buy below Maliki Bay that would be
a bonus I did a video the back end of
last year talking about my property
business plan in 2018 I am crushing it
this year so I will be doing more
updates and maybe give you some tours of
some of the properties that I bought or
have been buying or I'm about to buy
and I talked a little bit about why
weston-super-mare what while I was
attracted to that because it's a seaside
area and all the other seaside areas
across England have gone up considerably
with the regeneration weston-super-mare
is currently in the process they're
gonna spend quite a bit of money doing
it regenerating it and I just sense that
it's gonna go up quite quite a bit I
don't think you can buy seaside
apartments dance down the south of the
country for 80,000 pounds I don't think
that's going to be the case of very long
just arrived and it is beautiful
can't really see on here but what did
the Amanda
see the seaside looks fantastic we so
just viewed our first property one of
seven and it was good it was good it had
sea views which was fantastic the the
return investment wasn't incredible
really good picking the estate agents
Brian he was telling me all about the
area also saying that the Western
Superman market follows Bristol and
Bristol's gone crazy over the last two
or three years so he's expecting you
know some some serious appreciation he
said that the minute things were a
little bit static because of brexit and
people wouldn't be what's going to
happen but yeah very interesting I think
if you want to get a really good
knowledge about an area just make sense
to just book a whole bunch of views and
pick the estate agents brains because
depending on the agent you know some of
them have got quite a lot of local
knowledge about the property market so
just make sense also interesting picking
the stages brains about service
accommodation none of them have a clue
what it is
so far but it obviously exists because
there are holiday apartments around so
time to do some more market research
this one's fantastic beautiful you've
got two bedrooms and the ground rental
service charges are really love comes
down to three hundred and fifty pounds
pretty pretty reasonable okay that last
CV one was my favorite
it's on for 140 if we can get that for
less than 120 we are laughing and I
think my wife would agree I mean the
bottom line is it's all about what it
will rent out for so when you invest in
property as I always say there's only
two figures that you look at what you're
putting in what you're getting out
and then you divide the two between them
and it gives you a return on investment
and that's about it the things you need
to look for when you're in a street if
you like a terrible area is their broken
glass on the floor does it look like a
red light district anywhere I also have
their boarded up windows does it look
what the hole places his dad's or likes
a ghost town here that is absolutely not
the case it's absolutely buzzing you
know really like it I bought two
apartments in Warsaw Walsall Town Center
about nine years ago
and they've actually dropped they've
dropped in value and I know a lot of
people if I wanted one of my mentees he
said that he had a out of house for ten
years he didn't go up at all in fact he
dropped in value and he was got annoyed
and then sold the house and that was
about ten years ago when he sold the
house in the last ten years is doubled
in value twice it's quite by 200% so if
it wasn't to buy an apartment in
weston-super-mare but don't find
anything today that I really love I'll
probably buy one moment where would you
like to go you want to take a seat all
right you need help sitting down to
everyone with a broken egg helping old
ladies cross the road anyway where was I
I'll be putting in a lot of offers today
but they will be below market value
offers because if there's a lot of
properties there's a lot to choose from
then it puts the investor or the fire in
a stronger position to negotiate Amanda
now Mandy can you guess what I want to
figure out if you look that way how do
you get to that oh absolutely
and who owns it and what's on it all
that kind of stuff so it's now day 2 and
we literally got home last night
and we all walked out and fell asleep so
we've now got we've got a couple of use
today
but more importantly today is about
market research so we're going to be
speaking to the letting agencies see
what they get back to rental demand this
and how much will get crunching our
numbers put some offers in this we get
back
so ya get a big day with beautiful views
see see you hit the road now with an
appointment save got appointments who
actually happens we just going to turn
up to some listing agents and so it's
really important to just like meet lots
of people that have got knowledge in the
area
investors letting agents estate agents
you know all toasting people pick their
brain about their area ask them
questions but be conscious that they
might lie to you because they might have
an agenda usually people do have an
agenda so for instance the previous
three viewings we did
number five six seven was with the
letting agent he was really really nice
guy and really nice guy he showed us a
few properties but we were trying to
find out if Seaview would get you a lot
more rent because property number two
had a really nice Eve you but he was
saying I know Steve you are no one cares
about Steve you receive you just usually
means lots of stairs and people hate
walking up stairs but the thing is he
didn't show us any CV property so he
didn't have any Seaview properties to
sell so because he didn't have any CV
properties to sell you know he's not
gonna say oh yes Eve used the best
because he's not selling Steve you so
you know do pick people's brain and go
around but just be really mindful of
people's agenda and also talk to more
per get more than one person's opinion I
was going in the hotels I was even
asking the here at the hotel I was
saying you know how's the hotel business
doing because it was it was almost fully
booked Premier Inn was fully booked in
weston-super-mare so I was thinking
serviced accommodation so I'm asking
lots of questions being aware of their
agenda and I think that's really
important we're moving into a new area
and doing your market research
[Music]
we got a picture up that'd be fine see
this place was fully booked up we happen
to have a cancellation at this place all
these hotels and they're all selling out
means that the service de Commendation
probably would work here when you're
buying an apartment to do a service
accommodation you need to make sure that
you check the least make sure that you'd
be allowed to do that also you need to
get the right kind of mortgage you also
need to make sure that you can put a key
safe outside and it's okay it's the
right type of setup for the apartment so
there's quite a few factors it's
important just to see what the actual
center is like it's pretty decent it's
quite busy just in brightest move and
I'm chatting with a cool guy called
Steve who actually knows me from the TV
right Steve yes he knows me from the TV
and do you think I've got a good buyer
then stayed with you Steve use two
bedrooms
you reckon our beds get which is which
is great bit more conservative on camera
he knows our whole into it then but
that's great so these guys have been
fantastic really appreciate help thanks
very much and you're not you're not
super excited about it cuz you get way
more returns in Birmingham with an HMO I
mean in the hope that all yeah capital
appreciation that are you gonna get more
in the house at some point it just seems
a bit it's not like oh yeah sign me up
now yeah she's been trying to well this
but now it makes sense I mean I guess
yeah you're saying you
you gotta remember we are in Somerset we
are down south but I don't know where
we're going to put some orphan in the
walkway Mandy's making me put in the
office very cheeky yeah cheeky offers
and then if we get it then at least it's
a bargain yeah that's right yeah yeah
renting them out as a single net would
be a sensible exit strategy but this
doesn't really stack up so what are they
going to do this is serviced
accommodation or we're gonna need to get
below market value Deal accepted all
right time to put in some some offers
and see what happens we went into
Belvoir today and we spoke to the girls
nearly as to what you'd get for it and
things like that we can put an offer on
both of these properties but it is gonna
be a little bit less than the asking
price
I hope not some offense I'll tell you
what we're thinking and then you can
kind of just tell me if you think it's
worth putting forward or not that's okay
because they are technically like two
bedrooms but the bedroom the second
bedroom is a real courtroom it will
affect the rent ability of a lot the
price will get so the max really would
be able to go so it'd be about 115 and
then we could do 117 so that's kind of
what we were thinking based on the rent
and thing Cheers
what do you recommend drinking that
except I think she doesn't there isn't
give much away yeah she didn't give much
away but if it was ridiculous you
wouldn't like it wasn't it's not
ridiculous all right but I think do you
think if we got them for those prices
would you be happy yeah would you be
alright with that because then because
they're gonna shoot because too bad for
like 115 in the really good location god
yeah so alright we'll see what happens
okay I've just viewed my final property
before time to go home but the offers
have got back to me hear what they said
you were sleeping with yeah I caught ya
so the property that we offered the two
bad seed you we offered 115 they said no
I'm glad when they say no because if
they just say yes right away it means
that you could have maybe bought it for
lower they said no they said the one 117
and the other one are thinking about it
but they said no but they're gonna come
back so 117 so we have to know do we buy
one hundred seventeen thousand pounds
Seaview two bedrooms right in the center
posh straight do we buy it go on there
she says she takes more time thinking
about what shoes and handbag to buy than
she does about the houses but great so
that's one in the bag den 117,000 pounds
I think we probably call it a day now
buy that one see how it goes and hasty
view so if ever it's empty we could
always come you before daughter she
refers Dorset but it's good so that's
the conclusion guys one house bought and
when it goes up in value which it
probably will if maybe in a couple of
years I'll do another video about it and
explain what happened so I think the
next stop is Scotland
your touch I never wanna give it you can
never get me way too much
[Music]